[Music]
hello and welcome to internet version of
trailer commentaries for the Incredibles
2 hopefully you just watch Incredibles 2
honest trailer and then you come check
this out to get me and Joe and Dan's mi
a thoughts about the film will behind
the scenes will speak for Dan will speak
for Dan he likes lots of things he does
I don't like anything and if you stick
around there will be some deleted scenes
which I hope you do like yeah it's not
fair you don't like anything and he
likes a lot of things he likes plenty of
things yeah and so do I yeah sorry we
were just talking when space cowboys
before this is how many horses Clint
Eastwood killed on his way to the moon
and that's what I'd rather talk about
but whatever Incredibles - it's a sequel
to Incredibles yeah you saw the first
one it was delightful you saw the second
one it was nice you probably forgot
about but you also enjoyed it yeah and
that makes for some tough honest trailer
and don't do it really bears Spencer
it's tougher than going to the moon NASA
won't even return your phone calls yeah
I mean I was just a simple banker from
Boston trying to get my wagon to the
Oregon Trail which is on the moon you
did you chose banker you bought the most
ammo I was it to shoot Buffalo man I
didn't care for Ford in that River or
not I was a I was a whatever the broke
one was and I I tried to just make it
there alone and have everyone else die
that was the real the real victory I
know that was the first time I ever
knocked on a kid was playing Oregon
Trail what yeah what do you narc on a
kid for playing organ trail for it we
were in like The Contender land in like
second grade yeah and and one of his
people died and on the tombstone he
wrote he wrote Dolly Parton has big
boobies for telling the truth
oh yeah Incredibles 2 is a film from
Bradburn the Pixar entertainment
features family of superheroes it does
the guy they basically made a perfectly
good Marvel movie totally a perfectly
good Fantastic Four sequel they learned
to work together as a family and it
looks great they've tried out some of
the old favorites so that that their
Edna it's got a fun bit again they give
zones wife sure does yell out of she
yells at him he yells back and they do
they do some world-saving
from a tech genius who secretly is a
supervillain yeah hmm yeah sorry I I
just sent you guys like a super rough
draft in some notes and then said I'm
going on vacation you guys finish this
it's fine dad I picked a good week yeah
yeah no it's fine you you left us a
perfectly good a perfectly serviceable
rough draft yeah great and yeah this
this movie again it's fine it's like a
good superhero movie but I think I
expect more from Pixar then yeah I
expect more from Pixar on a on a
messaging and storytelling perspective
it looks incredible like this is where
the best-looking animated films I've
ever seen action sequences are so cool
naturally all I remember about it now
though it was like the last a bike chase
yeah but I feel like the you know the
Pixar movies they have such a clear
message or not even a message but just
like a feeling that you can attach to
like Toy Story and it's usually a real
thing where it's like toy stories about
the fear of being like left behind for
someone something new you know the fear
of like growing up and growing out of
something and you can do that through
all of their best works but this one
it's like what is it about is it like
I'm awesome and everyone else is holding
me back
yes the point but then I should also
check myself but then also I don't
really at but I shouldn't have to
because the I mean the first one is
about coming to terms with middle age
yes marriage and like yeah how can we
bring the excitement back into our lives
and like live joyously again yeah this
one's just like we want to shoot baby
lasers at people and scream if you won't
let us yeah and then there was kind of
like it there's a half step towards an
interesting point with screen slaver and
like you yeah this
you need to get off of your screens and
yeah but but there's no message coming
from the villain yeah and well not
considering who made the movie right
which we talked about which we talked
about a little bit but yeah I don't
think did the last thing Disney wants is
for everyone to be like you know what
villains say when they weren't
absolutely right and I disagree what
they did but good points Thanos screen
slaver oneness is top watching stuff
yeah
Maisie started it
yeah they scared it didn't fully it
wasn't there's a certain clarity to most
Pixar films as far as story goes that I
think was my sitting here yeah but still
a fun fun ride let's look at the thing
didn't you miss it yeah 14 years after
you fell in love with the Incredibles
your favorite super family returns with
an all-new adventure how's the best
reason right you guess you know unless
you remember anything at all about the
first movie you can't count on anyone
especially your heroes the just briefly
on the raccoon thing Jack Jack he's
watching television and he's watching a
a old-timey thief uh hold people up I
think at a jewelry store he's robbing
someone yeah and he can he makes the
connection by looking at the thief with
the black mask yep and then he looks at
the raccoon whose fur pattern is similar
which that profiling that it's been not
only he's profiling and uh but doesn't
his whole family wear the exact he's
gonna go after them as soon as they
change into costume I am completely we
went a little harder on it and a couple
of earlier drafts of this but um I think
my Jack Jack enjoyment varied from the
enjoyment of other people's Jack Jack
yeah I enjoyed it I think that it didn't
service the story was just like here's
fun side cartoons it reminded me of the
the cat and mouse in Cinderella it's
like we're gonna polish on Cinderella
and show some Looney Tunes yeah mine was
more like Oh minions I get it
look it's no menu the Binion's are
perfectly they're fun in the first one
will sprinkle a minion yeah a little
sprinkle a Jack Jack would have been
fine but then everything became about
any time the movie was like and here's a
nice teleport diapers they knew they had
a hit all right especially your heroes
superheroes keep us weak the same it
actually picks our target demo was Jack
Jack's age back then Incredibles to
experienced fan favorite director Brad
Bird six feature film and is forth about
how regular Schmucks like us need to
suck it up and let the gift play by
their own rules I mean that's the that's
the common theme whether he will admit
it or not is its Tomorrowland is about
the geniuses need to have their owners
have rise until they leave us behind
same with the Incredibles they need to
have they don't need to obey the law or
go through criminal process this
brilliant rat gets to do his thing in
the grass it's a touch our food because
he's really good I'll give him that one
I think that the the charitable reading
of him isn't that he's like a brand like
the individual supreme person the
Frozone head yeah I was looking at his
at his career and like he was one of
those guys that clearly was a genius and
was really struggling until middle age
like he was just kind of kicked around
and didn't his animation ideas were
rejected and he finally was like see
like I was right all along
yeah yeah I get it so I think it's
probably more autobiographical than it
is like write what you know yeah write
what you know right I'm a genius and you
all need to get out of my way Dolly
Parton as you know what continues their
tradition of passable sequels that don't
hit the mark of the first one except
that one time when it was even better
and then one time when it was so so much
worse agent you mean like insurance
like like a good neighbor mater is God
someday we're just gonna start releasing
John's unused vocal tracts because we
have like 30 great takes of John just
screaming now for this good well you got
the best one yep definitely paid off
with the incredibles
Bob is a dad who just wants to turn his
children into living weapons just what's
a cool action set piece of her own for
once
last time they learned to trust each
other and fight crime as a family unit
after a mishap where one of the parents
did illegal hero work on behalf of a
techno genius who turned out to be a
villain and the public learned to love
superheroes again now after 15 minutes
of erasing all that progress
once the poor's learn to trust each
other again and fight crime as a family
unit again after a mishap or one of the
parents does illegal hero work again on
behalf of a technolgies again who turns
out to be a villain again and the public
the next what happened I didn't give you
one point to screen labor a villain who
uses screens to hurt people including
the audience she believed in dangerous
menace we should rely on I think there's
the scene where they're fighting really
yeah they're fighting inside a apartment
or whatever yeah and it's like a cage
which is a great sequence sequence to
hurt people hurt me yeah not triggering
an epileptic seizure but I was like oh
oh see I watched this on a laptop like
the like the experience calls for now
this was definitely like that a that
Pokemon scene where some work there it's
polysome Holly something polyamorous no
Polly Polly whatever alright he's
flashing red-and-blue real fast okay and
Pikachu fights him and I'm like wow this
would put me into everything yeah kids
man they can take it
can be let's keep going let's find out
after this but this we shouldn't rely on
which the movie never really disputes
some incredibly solid points about the
harm of society's non-stop consumption
of media which of course makes her the
villain in a Disney movie shut up evil
lady that wants us to go outside real
heroes are already subscribed to Disney
streaming service yeah the exact same
dynamic is the first time around that's
still incredibly charming and holy moly
does it look good but after 20 films
have another Pixar movie is a chasing
for a climax I'm gonna dash myself up a
cliff other ways to end a film you know
I just switch things up with a huge
world ending thread that like menaces
people by projecting some kind of like
sky beam or something wait I guess they
would hate the most it's like a kids
movie can't end with like a murder Toy
Story for they're all just ripping each
other apart
yeah like BattleBots yeah that's that's
the Toy Story for I want just full
Thunderdome yeah just fluff going
everywhere yeah and a nice plastic mist
yeah I guess that is the only
kid-friendly action scene is the chase
tag
I'll get you do something yeah that's
all I can think of I was like maybe they
can solve a big puzzle and then I was
like that's the stupidest maybe they can
pump the brakes and I'll sit down and
have a nice brain teaser yeah yeah like
the one at Cracker Barrel were you
jumping golf tees sorry what you ever
been to a Cracker Barrel not in a decade
well there's a little brain teaser you
hacker barrel okay and it's a little
triangular block of wood yeah and
there's a little golf tees and except
one of the holes is empty and you got to
jump golf tees dark times before
iPads and distracted yeah no smell teas
now Cracker Barrel has an iPad at the
table and you open it and there it is oh
this is so much better
there's microtransactions he could buy
Incredibles to golf tees yeah alright
let's keep going
never mind chase away to infinity and
beyond starring down with a thickness
triangle man triangle man streaks in
Dior all that's good take from
incredible redness here no one of them
is sob the old in Kirk and Catherine
Keener just really wanted to play
another hypnotist sisters moms and dads
Super Smash Bros ultimate very excited
for ya Incredibles everyone knows Jack
Jack has powers we found out in the last
movie and Rick digger found out from the
babysitter and Jack Jack Attack kind of
surprised you didn't clue you in on all
this that's a real rig dicker move rig
dicker as a funny name
yeah they also really expected the
audience to remember and have a lot of
affection for Rick dicker from
incredible oh yeah really oh man like
goodbye Rick we're gonna miss you you've
done so much like dear favorite
character yeah sleepy government agent
they also really expected like I was
when everyone's like Jack Jack has
powers I was like yeah he like you're
all staring at him in the air cuz Jason
Lee had him yeah and they turn into a
big old pink monster and you were look
you're looking y'all were looking y'all
were looking and then yeah y'all so
y'all saw y'all so bad yeah II have a
dance okay let's see what you guys
didn't see on these here deleted scenes
and if you think they're gonna mess with
this formula for the next one
I can give you one point two billion
reasons why they won't 1.2 billion holy
crap that's like supervillain money
stories and million Papa smirk Dashboard
Confessional possible we were really
trying to Joe you really want it I
really wanted to make this work
sometimes Spencer will be like hey you
were supposed to have this done hours
ago and he'll find out that I've just
spent like the morning trying to make
one pun work I have yeah I really wanna
- really what a dad for confessional to
work if ever did it never did
so you comment below now's your chance
try to make a pun that makes sense with
Dashboard Confessional
and The Incredibles - that was the best
we could do yep so the challenges is
open starting now I won't be checking
anytime no kid flash flash in the
Furious not an invisible girl not yet an
invisible woman Paulson boiler that
jokes become likely as an Elle sketch
that every go polymorph in fix a rager
yes they deserve to die and I hope they
peaked in hell the Winter Soldier mr.
shell bode I mean on TV
Evelyn endeavor evil endeavor oh now I
get it you only gave us a Bella
Rosellini like two lines okay and B
Incredibles 3 and the Avengers super bad
jack-jack featuring The Incredibles and
hope he does good work oh hey guys
the baby was cute and everything but
take a cue from grew a little minions
goes a long way you had a minions tag
was in there yeah Wow okay everybody
like Jack checks is a little more than
me you're you're off the Jack Jack train
yeah just not on the Grinch and Jack
Jack just two things I'm not on board
with mmm - wait apparently I missed a
whole thing where you hate the Grinch
last week yeah you did I leave for one
week and now you hate the Grinch without
telling me yeah I had a bad day
ah grinch billboard man you shot a guy
on some great billboard
I know I'm mr. Hank yellows so you saw
billboard Joey it sounds like you need a
vacation man we should trade off man
that'd be cool
yeah take one man I think can you you
know what no matter where I go in the
continental US and possibly the globe
there will be a green Grinch billboard
that's true somewhere that's like it's
like stop coming to Italy we're full
localize it for every nation yeah yeah
there's these movies they're worldwide
there worldwide phenomena they really
are lets us do what we do and what we do
is talk with mild interest about
Incredibles - for about 15 to 20 minutes
every day and that's the screen junkies
promise that's right we'll be back next
week hopefully with Dan we really need
him to ground the show I wasn't here for
this one what can I say
this one's on you Joe and yeah next week
we're gonna give me a little clue it's
it's it's a big one
literally it's very very big yeah I
don't want to make it obvious ya know
but it's real big very large mm-hmm yeah
huge there you go all right see you next
week bye
you
[Music]